it's interesting it's it feels like one
of those things where even just two
white guys talking about this in 2020
like we need to be in a bunker we need
to be protected we can't even say what
we're saying
i'm just gonna give them a problem yeah
i'm gonna give my [ __ ] jerry springer
yani long day thought of the day
let's do it you gotta stop [ __ ]
judging people
on their person and revering or hating
people
based on ad hominem attacks listen to
what they say
cherry pick what you like create your
own thing whether they be liberal or
conservative
and fix it baby because life is a
farmer's market and you can't just leave
what cookies i will say i will say one
thing about you is even though you have
one eye you always do see two sides i
two
i see two sides with my one eye but you
had a meeting with the producers and we
said you know what cause you're the
dennis rodman of this podcast
yes whatever is going we just got to go
with the flow babe if you [ __ ] sho if
you come in we're naked
we play we do the podcast whatever you
do we do
we don't ask questions we don't judge if
you come in with a guy and you say this
is my husband
we go that's his husband today guy
because if we looked at your dms would
you say
you are the most equal opportunity dmr
because i guess you're [ __ ] your dms
proves how much of a lover of all races
you are
i'm a lover of all races you will see my
dms
i'm telling you it will not discriminate
against color creed or religion at all
as long as you got a big dick you're
getting a dna
you'll take whatever cuz your dick is
like the statue of liberty
yeah i'm going to call your dick ellis
island give me your tired you're hungry
whatever cuz
it's what it is because you [ __ ]
everybody [ __ ] everybody because my
haircut's a [ __ ] nazi my dick's a
black panther
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]